okay what is the average woman bringing
yes we're talking about average average
means already that it doesn't bring much
right and women are being forced to
bring on the table things that I think
for men is not very useful anymore so
we've been forced like if you talk to
most of girls here they have like really
good jobs working for governments high
education and that's not what men's need
like in a relationship like sex if you
put on the top for men's number one and
unfortunately the other things affect
women on this way and things like this
why were women forced to get jobs you
don't think it was a choice Spartan
women were forced to get jobs I think
nowadays he has a very big pressure okay
a really big pressure
very well educated and have a job of
course if you live in London if you
don't work if you don't make money the
city is gonna swirl right